Film Courage: What makes a good story?William
C. Martell: What makes a good story?
A good story…
here is the thing: there is this thing called
the ‘skin jump,’ did I talk about this
last time?
Good.
I’ll talk about it this time.
A skin jump is where, we as the audience,
jump on to the screen and become the protagonist
in the story.
And a good story has some sort of a fantasy
(it doesn’t have to be a positive fantasy)
that we want to explore in our life, so we
skin jump and we are Elliott riding his bicycle
with E.T. and it flies.
That is one of those moments where if you
were to turn the camera on the audience and
watch the audience they would all just be
overjoyed, because we’re all Elliott in
that scene for that moment!
We can become Indiana Jones and do the amazing
adventure thing.
And we basically jump from the audience on
to the screen which means we need a character
to jump into.
A good story is about a character that fulfills
some sort of dream fulfillment.
Some sort of fantasy the audience has and
the reason why a film is a hit is because
it ends up hitting the dream fulfillment elements
of a lot of people.
And so if you can figure out the zeitgeist
of the audience, what people are dreaming
about right now, that is the thing that is
going to pull us on to the screen.
But it doesn’t have to be a positive thing.
I did a film noir class here (referring to
Story Expo 2015) and the film noir often jumps
us into people that do bad things because
we all secretly want to do bad things.
But we can’t, so….there’s a lot of movies
about career criminals because we all some
times want to break the law.
There are a lot of movies about people that
do terrible, awful things that kill people
that…like Horrible Bosses, that kill their
bosses because we have that ‘thing’ going
on inside of us.
That is the dream fulfillment of that story.
So a good movie is dream fulfillment to the
audience.
The audience fantasizes about something, hopefully
as part of that audience, we fantasize about
some of those things, too.
A weird movie is where someone has their dream
fulfillment and you go ‘What kind of a sick
weirdo is that dream?’
And you see those sometimes and go “What’s
going on here?”
A good story is going to allow the audience
to jump into that character and take that
character on an adventure.
It can be a good adventure, it can be a bad
adventure but we’re going to go along with
that story.
So that means there is going to be a great
conflict in there some place, that means the
thing that often happen is a romance of some
sort or another because even if it’s E.T.,
it’s a boy and his dog story, but the dog
is an alien and there is no more unconditional
love than from your dog or ….I don’t know
if your cat loves you?
But your dog loves you no matter what.
So that is something we can fantasize about,
we can get into that story, we can understand
that story and jump into Elliott’s life
with E.T. and it’s the kid who bring the
pet home that mom doesn’t want and has to
hide it in the closet, one of those things,
“oh, I found a stray dog,” but the stay
dog is an alien.
Now the dog catcher wants him and the dog
catcher’s keys and the guy from the government
(in E.T.).
It’s basically finding that story and finding
a new stake on that story because that could
have been just a dog story but by making it
the alien were not telling the story we’ve
already heard, we’re telling a story that
is new and different, that gives us a different
experience than what we’ve had before.
I don’t know if that even answers the question?
QUESTION FOR THE VIEWERS: If you could spend
the next 24 hours as any character and live
in their world, which one would it be?